well this is a great great honor I'm
presenting the narrative filmmaking
award and I was I queued all these up
and and thought I would take a quick
little peek at home but each one of them
and I ended up watching them through
their through their entirety and and
every one of them is amazing I mean
they're they're really extraordinary
there's some winners here obviously that
come out of the AFI program in the first
winter tonight oh yeah oh yeah give it
up all right all right
the our bronze medal winning filmmaker
tonight is Justin tipping
but Justin made a movie called Nanai and
it follows a young Hispanic boy named
Oscar as a graffiti artist and a rough
part of town he gets sentenced to
community service he ends up in a
nursing home he meets a 84 year old
woman named Isabel and they have
incredible differences but form a
relationship and it's one of those
things would be hard to create this
relationship in an hour and a half of a
movie and he somehow manages to do it in
in 15 minutes this is overwhelming if I
faint to throw up somebody please take
the scribbles I wrote his bullet points
and finished the speech for me first off
I like to thank the Academy never
thought I'd say that sentence in my life
before only in front of a mirror and
occasionally in the shower as a joke but
I got to say it tonight like to thank
the American Film Institute the faculty
and staff and all of the mentor
mentorship excuse me and guidance you've
given me you changed my life and I would
not be in this position without all of
you there's too many people to thank
I'd like to thank my grandmother who
whether she knows it or not what
inspires inspired me and was the
emotional impetus for this story and I
would like to thank the my fellow
classmates who enabled me to tell this
story and that is Joshua from golden so
in your Lynda you'll mom Bonnie Boston
West McDowell without you guys I could
never have done this and a piece of all
of your collaboration and creativity was
shown on the screen and it was a joint
effort and I most importantly cherish
all those stories and friendships that
we have and hope they last and of course
Sai Chen Johnny Ortiz who I don't know
how we found each other in this world
but we did and I'm just blessed to have
worked with both of you so
thank you from the bottom of my heart
and to my family
all right hmm my who and my brothers and
brothers and sister who have always
supported me and my mom and dad who with
me through the worst of times
couldn't have done it without you and to
uh Wow geez Academy yeah the statues and
the Cuba all right I'll spit I'll wrap
this up I just want to say I'm just I
hope that myself and the ten other
winners tonight can continue telling the
stories that matter and that we're
passionate about with the same you know
respects and integrity that the
filmmakers before have before us have
done as well so thank you